unwinding in room 77 in this Berlin bar
you can pay for your beer with bitcoins
yog phone mink wits often pays with
bitcoins I'm not convinced yet for euros
at three point three nine milli bitcoins
for a coke the great thing about new
currencies like Bitcoin is that you can
also use them for tiny sums room 77 is a
Bitcoin hangout I'd like to find out how
I can open a Bitcoin account and how the
system works two entrepreneurs set up
the digital bit Wyler Bank in 2012 the
blockchain banking service now has 12
employees
I log on to their website to open a
Bitcoin account you have to be
registered with the police have internet
access and have some money what's
unusual is that I have to read out my ID
card details on a video linked with the
bank an online banking security check
I've never come across before commercial
banks levy hefty fees for foreign
transactions if I want to transfer 500
euros to China say a normal bank will
charge me 50 euros and it'll take
several days before the money gets there
with bitcoin transfers the money's there
instantly the fee to euros 50 half a
percent we say the old system wasn't
made for internet speeds
and also not for the internet the new
technologies we use mean international
money transactions have minimal costs
almost in real time and that's something
the banking system has not managed to
accomplish to this day bit Walla has
20,000 clients with a hundred joining up
every day they convert over 20
currencies for customers in over 120
countries they mainly use bitcoins to
transfer international fees and wages
the main customers are electronics
companies sending money to their Chinese
suppliers there are plenty of
freelancers among them who work in
Germany and Europe but have their
programmers in India not only focused on
the lucrative traditional banking model
it's got some ambitious plans it aims to
facilitate money transfers between
computers in future machines we'll be
paying other machines directly they scan
each other every few seconds and settle
accounts just as fast in bitcoins of
course but can you make cash payments
with bitcoins for that I have to
download the company app to my mobile
and give the cash to managing director
yang GAO's Leakey what do you do I give
you money you give me euros and I give
you bitcoins
okay cuz Leakey transfer 17 and a half
millions into my new bit while I account
if I steal your mobile or you lose it
then your bitcoins are gone yeah that's
not the only danger anyone who hacks my
mobile can also get at the money my only
remedy is a memory stick or a hard drive
backup but now I'm itching to start
spending my bitcoins so it's off to a
book store that accepts the futuristic
currency a science fiction book shop the
great advantage for me bitcoin fees are
much lower than the fees for credit card
payments it's great that we as a
science-fiction book shop can offer a
currency of the future the bottom line
is that it's easier than you think I'll
probably still be paying in Euros in
everyday life but my next international
money transfer might well be made with
bitcoins